le padel un combo entre le squash et le
tennis une petite raquette en carbone
qui ressemble étrangement à celle du
jokari de plage une piste c'est ainsi
qu'on l'appelle en revêtement souple
synthétique recouvert d'une mince
pellicule de sable fin et une balle peu
gonflé qui provoque des coûts lourds et
bruyant
si la surface est largement plus petit
qu'un court de tennis le jeu n'en est
que plus rapide mais l'objectif reste
avant tout le pli
sport très ludique ont rapidement
ce tennis il faut énormément de
techniques donc vite fait on est en
train de s'amuser c'est très bien si
l'espagne compte plus de quatre millions
de joueurs la france on a déjà séduit 80
milles seul problème pour le moment le
manque de pistes la fédération française
de tennis contribuer à les développer et
de nouvelles structures fleurissent sur
le territoire c'est un sport qui va
prendre en son apogée j'irai dans
quelques années puisque on a une
recrudescence de jours de tennis qui
arrête le tennis pour pratiquer le
paddle pour différentes raisons là le
fait que ça soit un terrain assez souple
donc il permet aussi de ne pas avoir de
traumatismes au niveau des articulations
ça touche tout public aussi bien les
enfants à partir de 10 12 ans que les
anciens les seniors à plus de 70 ans
le padel a manqué la marche djo de
parking 24 ils étaient en lice mais il a
été devancé par le hip hop il fera
peut-être sa grande rentrée à los
angeles en 2028